and II any idea what you're gonna get
for Christmas this year anything uh no I
actually have no idea and I I know it's
it's kind of corny but I still kind of
like to be surprised I mean I love
waking up on Christmas morning and
seeing how Santa's stuff my stocking
okay I'm lazy man that's that's Tony one
of our cameramen Tony why is that funny
stuff your stocking that's that's right
Tony that's that's what Santa does Hey
hey Conan do you like getting your
stocking stuff absolutely it's a great
holiday tradition I love getting my
stocking stuff yeah yeah I bet you do
how about your wife the Santa's stuff
her stocking - he sure does yeah Santa
stuffs both of our stockings and my wife
loves it even more than I do
oh ma mine too absolutely she's crazy
about it yeah oh hey Conan when Santa's
stuff's just stocking
how does he gain access to your house I
mean like does he just walk in the front
door or is there I don't know what some
kind of alternate route well Santa comes
down my chimney yeah I'll bet he does
you know so he probably has a pretty
full sack when he comes down your
chimney huh
well if the number of presence under our
tree is any indication Santa's sack is
practically bursting when he gets to my
house then after he comes down my
chimney his sack is completely empty
yeah and then Santa has to empty his
sack down every chimney in the world I
mean his stamina is incredible okay we
got there got Todd Levi's a good big
pole Oh Santa you made it okay good good
good
all right guys check this out what's
this still Conan in summation would you
say that you like it when Santa comes
yeah I love when Santa comes and if I
had it my way I had it my way every
single night said it would come down my
chimney nibble on my cookies swallow my
milk then stuff my stocking and my
wife's talking then just beat it through
my back door with his giant sack
completely drain
[Laughter]
this segment brought to you by the
double entendre Council of America
additional funding provided by the Yule
Log polishers Union Peter North's
holiday eggnog house of yum-yum's extra
thick candy canes dick Peterson's hot
glazed hogs captain Quinn's Christmas
clam spread hardcore pornography even
the weird German stuff and ass unlimited
[Applause]
you